[Music]
so a husband
has made a very great error oh no he got
married
[Laughter]
it's worse
what
give away the house
no did he give away his wife didn't sign
a prune up just what's something that
you i mean we all do you guys have
family group texts we
oh no
yes and no yes but i avoid them yeah
i'll never respond but i never opened up
my line pretty much me too um yeah i
have like three thousand missed on there
but i keep my one family separate mine
and i'm in that group text with jio's
family because they're really cool yeah
i kind of do that too
it's interesting my my uh in-laws were
pretty fun my in-laws are pretty sick my
family's very cynical oh my god same
dude i don't want to hang around them so
too much no so a husband
a loving husband
accidentally sends
a completely naked photo of his wife to
their entire family
oh man
did he did he kill himself afterwards
contemplating suicide right now he's
currently contemplating i would too
i mean what position was she in that
doesn't really matter it does matter all
fours
with her [ __ ] spread open we hold her
but i would be so proud if my my my
daughter's husband sent me that one you
would yeah i'd be like go get them tiger
but that's but that could be your mom
too
if it's my mom i'll be like go get them
tiger you think so yeah
she's still [ __ ] that [ __ ] 78.
killing it
do your thing though
the closest thing i ever did to that was
um i texted geo's mom and i was like oh
no you're not gonna believe what
happened she's like what and then uh
we're at the gas station and tycho was
peeing but his pants is all the way down
so i took a picture of him peen in the
urinal with his butt cheek clean up and
i sent that to him so it's funny because
it's a little it's like did you meet the
senator
how dare you send child porn to your
mother i'm against that child porn is
illegal in a lot of states yeah dude not
in nevada
not all of them
that's why i sent it right before the
state line perfect so it's okay
so as you cross the state line so it's
interstate commerce
now the feds are after you
so this poor son of a [ __ ]
says that um this is the most
embarrassing moment of his entire life
yeah i agree so it all took place in the
delivery room right after
birth right after
they gave she was giving birth to her
son that's better
like the context is at least like uh
more wholesome rather than sexual or
whatever yeah cause you could you could
play it off you could play it off like
oh my god i was so excited the my
firstborn son is like coming out
unfortunately their family's really into
pregnant finishes oh well that's
unfortunate oh wait she took it's a
photo of her when she's
she's who is he meaning to send that to
you
yeah oh my god who is he meaning to send
that to uh he says that he he was just
excited after it he wasn't meaning to
send it at all
oh he butt centered he was trying to
send a family picture not that picture
it was right next to that one yeah i was
right next it was too fired up he needs
to organize his albums and that's true
and he sent it to his he sent the this
is this part's confusing because it says
the dad sent the photo to his mom who
sent it to the whole family why did they
do that
now there's two levels of wait that's
not his fault it's kind of his fault
could be his mom is just like look at
this you know because she has epilepsy
so she's she just didn't see what the
[ __ ] was going on because she fell
asleep while she's out yeah yeah yeah
look at this
the whole family
the pregnancy picture is also strobing
man
so it's one mess up and another mess up
back to back it's a double mess up she
the wife is handling it really well she
thinks it was pretty funny actually what
a great wife yeah and um but she um
you know she can't seem to get him to
come down from the from the ledge a
little bit the suicide watch yeah
because he's just so embarrassed about
it and can't believe where he should be
yeah
i think that just depends on like the
family though right like you know like
there's like
um families that are very comfortable
with certain things whether one there's
already like text threads i remember
ryan ryan was here talking about how
like you know there's like that grandma
who was shooting like tick tock videos
at like his studio and stuff like that
but then like her daughter was there and
then her daughter's children were there
like just watching the grandma and it
looks like only fan [ __ ] yeah yeah it
didn't look like tick-tock [ __ ] some
families are just really comfortable
like you know like steve and his sister
like kind of like you make out
very close it's just different very
close but she got married and rude and
everything
i um i used to sort out my my [ __ ]
like photo album thingy like on my phone
because that's what i was afraid of is
like if i'm sending something right like
what if my [ __ ] mountain biking
adventure jump is right next to a dick
pic and i hit the wrong one and it sends
and i'm like oh no i was hella scared of
that right oh no no they know i've
mountain bike jump on them
oh no oh no i meant the dick pig she
knows that i'm a [ __ ]
i had this girl she was so excited now
she sees me biking yeah
i met the dick pic no and i had
different uh albums for every single one
right i had albums of the girls i had
the dick i had everything right and then
when i kept looking at it
i just had to delete all my dick
pictures because i started feeling gay
what i get
they're all your dick though yes they
start looking at a different way
because every time you open it there's a
[ __ ] dick because the album cover but
if it's your dick it's not gay it's but
i don't but
it's still you got to look at a dick
when you look at the tiles you see dicks
yeah but if it's yours if it's yours you
don't associate it with you though it's
super gay it's perfection though nobody
wants a photo album full of dicks
especially if you're a guy dick's yeah
dick your dick looks right amazing and
it's a it's a it's a lot of it it's
different angles it looks different
literally start your day off the way i
see your phone all right yeah yeah
dick's
i swear to god i have never taken a
picture of my dick in my entire life oh
really it's a lot of fun you should do
bottom
you got to do the top you guys are only
so many ways to take a picture
never never done you got to do the angle
from over here you're still in it but
it's like huge yeah
and then you're you're you're holding it
like with the with the okay sign like
that
punch me
okay
you hold it with chopsticks yeah
like you're eating hot cheetos it's a
theme yeah it's a good theme
with tiny chopsticks too you really
never ever took a photo of your dick why
not what's wrong with you we have such
amazing
cameras aren't big enough yeah
they got 0.5
0.5 wide angle if if the [ __ ] legends
are true and steve has a big [ __ ]
dick right i i would literally take a
picture of my dick next to my arm like
this and just why would you do that
so i could choke perfect ratio
to see what are you the bone collector
putting a dollar next to a footprint
dude this guy's later putting a water
bottle messages for scale yeah
scale look at how tiny it is compared to
this water i would need to put my my
dick next to a bigfoot's [ __ ]
footprint
the empire state building
guys i can confirm steve's penis is huge
guys
what does it feel like in your hand
right now it wasn't in my hands
anyways um you're not supposed to tell
that story hey real talk though real
seriously do you have a single photo of
your dick in your phone right now i
delete it all ah good job dude you
wanted to see it yeah man i have my wife
bent over in every [ __ ]
position you could ever imagine
that's like what all that's in my is in
my phone basically you have no no
pictures of your dick poker chips
everywhere just [ __ ] dude cash money
i actually do have a photo
i'm gonna show you guys that no yeah no
nicki holding racks yeah dude that [ __ ]
was sick just topless or what no just
unfortunately cause we were on the way
to the airport but corner cam am i right
but yeah so uh
that was a pretty fun moment
taking taking money out like [ __ ] 116
000 or whatever and just taking a
stupid picture with it and she's like
sticking her tongue out and like doing
all stupid [ __ ] because we're laughing
about it but she got picked was it scary
going home with that cash yeah it's
[ __ ] frightening you're just like
walking to your car like can we get an
escort or something they they do give an
escort right or how does that work nah i
just well i was there so i was we just
shoved it into a bag and walked out
but i felt like a heist movie but what
if someone followed you that's how they
always get you yeah i know
yeah but guess what
eyes and back of my [ __ ] head
and jewelry [ __ ] taekwondo karate
dude taekwondo
purple belt [ __ ] what are you gonna do
about it i'll literally i need music but
i have forms dude you better play the
music though
[ __ ] remember i remember all of it
yeah you don't want to [ __ ] with me
you got a punch like this literally like
that yeah yeah that's good rotation
i'm telling you dude low-key pretty
funny himself came to my own dojo
and he would wear a gold ghee sparkly
gold like trump gold nice and then he
would make us all sit there and watch
him do a hundred push-ups before we
started so it'll take like [ __ ] 35
minutes
it took a long time oh dude this guy's
like 87 years old then i was like six
years old you think you could kick his
[ __ ] ass now i can kick his [ __ ]
lily ass dude
i went and peed on his grave
dying
yeah i was like you're a little [ __ ]
can't believe you died yeah yeah are you
are you a black belt you dying so easy
you die so so hard died of natural
causes my god
[Music]
[Music]
you